1 old man 2 boys at the bedside
that will be 1 trio tonight
during his internship in the hospital,
Vin received ST
hear more and more comments like this
that just took care of it
that I actually didn't feel like it anymore
to go to that patient
I think I want to live care for 1 patient
but actually I don't want to get there now
he decided to do research on it
and found out
that many male nurses
have to deal with it
I have also experienced this once
that I came to 1 room of 3 people
there were 3 elderly ladies
where 1 lady
could not take off her Bas herself per night
that I then
Get 1 comment from other 2 ladies in the room of
hey you will visit me soon
oh you can help me too
that you then leave the room with 1 different feeling
than you would like
SAY
according to Fin
men are less likely to talk about it than women
he thinks there should be more attention
I think there is 1 kind of taboo around it
the men you are as a man you should be strong
you have to be able to take 1 beating
so you cannot be a victim of sexual
transgressive behavior
me as a 22 year old guest
who helps ladies who is usually seen as one joke
that's fine but if i like him
change to 1 twenty year old lady
who is also a nurse
and comes to 1 room of 3 older men
and asks if they can put underpants down
and that the other men say
you will also visit me
then it will be picked up differently